[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing some of the spells of the
wizarding world
more specifically however we're going to
be discussing the five most evil spells
that is the spells considered too dark
for nobler more righteous wizards these
are the spells reserved for the darkest
of the dark
the supremely evil
before we get started i want to make a
distinction
there are plenty of spells which dark
wizards use that aren't necessarily
inherently evil
it's just that they're used in an evil
way that's not what i want to cover here
i want to cover the darkest of the dark
spells that couldn't ever possibly have
any sort of positive or good connotation
these are the spells of the dark arts
the dark arts are many varied
ever-changing and eternal
fighting them is like fighting a
many-headed monster which each time a
neck is severed sprouts ahead even
fiercer and cleverer than before you are
fighting that which is unfixed mutating
indestructible
some of the spells on this list are
curses
so what exactly is a curse
first you need to understand what a
charm is a charm is an expression that
refers to spells which add certain
properties to objects or individuals
charms should not be confused with
transfigurations
as transfiguration refers to a spell
that changes what the object is
rather than just changing properties of
the object
basically cursors are the most severe
form of dark charms often cast with
intent to kill or seriously harm
now that you've got a better sense of
what does what let's dive into the top 5
most evil spells in the harry potter
universe
5. sektum sempra part of the reason that
sektim's emperor makes it onto this list
besides its obvious malevolent nature is
the fact that it was created almost
entirely out of spite sektum's emperor
was invented by none other than severus
snape and we first hear of the spell
when harry discovers it in the
half-blood prince
sektum's emperor is a vicious dark curse
that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target often after being
struck the target will lay them
motionless as they lose blood
it is somewhat of a specialty of snapes
and is featured in his half-blood prince
copy of advanced potion making
in fact in snape's copy of the textbook
the spell is accompanied with a note
which says
four enemies
this alludes to just how dangerous the
spell is when harry uses it on malfoy in
the half-blood prince we see the spell
in action for the first time
and it's not a pretty sight
why harry thought it would be a good
idea to use an unknown spell on malfoy
for enemies is anyone's guess but all i
know is that both boys were lucky that
snape showed up the only thing that
detracts from this spell being possibly
more evil is that it has a counter charm
vulnerability the fact that the spell is
so easy to cast even harry can cast it
without knowing what it does
and the fact that snape created it out
of such a dark place to use on the
marauders speaks volumes to just how
twisted this curse really is
for that reason it's number five on the
list
four fiend fire next up we have one of
the most powerful spells in the entire
harry potter universe fiend fire
it was not normal fire crab had used a
curse of which harry had no knowledge as
they turned a corner the flames chased
them as though they were alive sentient
intent upon killing them
now the fire was mutating forming a
gigantic pack of fiery beasts flaming
serpents chimeras and dragons rose and
fell and rose again and the detritus of
centuries on which they were feeding was
thrown up in the air into their fanged
mouths tossed high on clawed feet before
being consumed by the inferno for those
unaware fiendfire is absurdly
overpowered
and its basic function is to destroy
everything
voldemort is a known proponent of the
spell and can be seen using it against
dumbledore in their epic jewel in the
ministry atrium
fiendfire produces enchanted flames of
an enormous scale that essentially
destroy anything in its path often
taking the form of gigantic fiery beasts
fiendfire is extremely advanced dark
magic and is also one of only a few
known ways to destroy a horcrux fiend
fire is pure evil because its only
purpose is to destroy
it can't really be used righteously
which is why it shouldn't surprise you
that it's a no-go for many powerful dark
wizards for that reason it's number four
on the list three imperial surprise
surprise one of the unforgivable curses
but i'll have you know that not all of
them are on this list what are the three
invisible curses you ask let's have fake
moody explain
now those three curses avada kedavra
imperius and cruciatus are known as the
unforgivable curses
the use of any one of them on a fellow
human being is enough turn a life
sentence in azkaban the imperius curse
or imperio comes from the latin impero
which means i command
imperio is most often used by dark
witches and wizards and when it's cast
on a victim they are forced to perform
the unquestioned bidding of the caster
being under the control of this spell is
said to be like experiencing a wonderful
release from any sense of responsibility
making the victim extremely susceptible
to any sort of influence from the caster
because of this adopted carefree
attitude the victim is inclined to carry
out tasks for the caster without any
sort of moral compass or awareness of
the caster's intentions or desires fake
moody explains the properties of
imperial further in the lesson
i can make it jump out of the window
drown itself throw itself down one of
your throats
this dark curse can basically make
people do anything
kill their families destroy a school and
for that reason it's certainly one of
the most evil spells in existence
2. crucio
like imperial above crucio is one of the
unforgivable curses
the cruciatus curse aka crucio literally
translates to i torture in latin so you
can already begin to get an idea of what
this spell does and why it's here on the
list crucio is most often used by dark
witches and wizards and a known pronoun
of crucio is bellatrix the strange who
used it to torture alice and frank
longbottom
when cast crucio inflicts excruciating
pain on the victim
pain so excruciating that it is
considered to be torturous casting
crucio is said to require a want and
incantation
and its effects are said to vary
depending on the caster's desires and
emotions for best results the caster
must despise the victim and enjoy
causing pain
when harry tried to use it on bellatrix
it just didn't work that well and that's
because he's just not messed up enough
to use it crucio is the spell of torture
and it doesn't get much more evil than
torture 1. the horcrux creation spell
even magik most evil a dark arts
reference book that focuses on dark
magic refused to touch on the creation
of a horcrux
of the horcrux wickedest of magical
inventions we shall not speak nor give
direction
that alone should be enough to put it
the top of this list but let me expand
on things a bit further generally
speaking we don't exactly know what is
involved with this spell
but what we do know is that murder is
necessary
the horcrux creation spell is used to
create a horcrux an object in which a
dark witch will wizard imparts a piece
of their soul in order to achieve
immortality it's widely considered to be
the most terrible form of dark magic and
for good reason
this spell affects both the victim as
well as the caster
as in sheer defiance of life itself it
rips out and redistributes the soul
it opposes the fundamental laws of magic
in fact it's so evil that even most dark
witches and wizards avoid this spell
slughorn puts it best himself
few would want it tom very few
death would be preferable
and that's it for this video avada
kadavra didn't make it onto the list
because in a weird sort of way it's
merciful
it's like death by lethal injection it
kills instantly and while it's still
certainly evil i think the spells on
this list are far more sinister what's
your list let me know down in the
comment section below
until next time remember tampa with the
deepest mysteries the source of life the
essence of self
only if prepared for consequences of the
most extreme and dangerous kind
[Music]
you